9 c'est la fresque de la discorde celle
adama traoré à stains fraises qui
représente on l'a dit adama traoré à
côté de georges de floyd et cette
inscription dessus contre le racisme et
des violences policières
et c'est ce qui provoque la colère des
syndicats de police pour en débattre non
sommes nous avec azzedine taïbi maire
pcf de stains à ses côtés yves assure ma
secrétaire régional idf syndicat
alliance et notre face à face ce soir
bonsoir à tous les deux messieurs
azzedine tazi billets yvan as you may
lors le rassemblement policiers 1 qui
devait avoir lieu cet après midi à
stains pour dénoncer cette phrase n'a
finalement pas eu lieu à la place la
délégation a été reçue à la préfecture
de seine saint denis vous avez fait part
de votre mécontentement ils vont axioma
oui tout à fait donc nous sommes
rassemblés donc devant la préfecture de
la seine-saint-denis et nous avons
demandé à être reçus par le préfet de la
seine-saint-denis ce qui a été fait nous
allons nous a reçus ont bien fait part
de notre mécontentement mais que lui
même avait déjà exprimé auprès du maire
de st monsieur le préfet nous il nous
l'a bien confirmé
il avait déjà contacté le maire de
stains pour lui faire part de son
indignation par rapport à 7
cette fresque ou plutôt le le fait le
fait que le maire de saint il cautionner
cette fraise et surtout la phrase qui
est comme on l'a vu dans le reportage
la phrase qui est à stricte en haut de
cette phase et c'est cette phrase qui
prêtent à kiki et tout le
le coeur de cette polémique parce que
cette phrase encore une fois elle fait
un amalgame
il n'y a pas lieu de faire c'est un
raccourci sam est créé que ça ne fait
qu'attiser une haine et créer de la
confusion dans l'esprit des gens comment
vous qu'on est on inscrit comme ça et
surtout qu'on cautionne puisque c'est ce
que le maire de stains fait en
inaugurant cette fresque en la présence
du collectif justice pour adama il ay là
il a grandement sa part de
responsabilité
dans l'intelligence aurait dû lui
rappeler et lui faire découvrir de lui
même que cette phrase à les poser
problème
pascal jeter encore une fois le
discrédit sur l'ensemble de la
profession
c'est vraiment plus qu'un raccourci
c'est réducteur de marquer racisme
violence policière parce que bien sûr
c'est lourd de sous-entendus et monsieur
le maire des stars on a conscience
c'est lourd de sous-entendus parce que
ça prétend que dans les policiers dans
leur ensemble sont racistes que ça
prétend que les policiers sont dans leur
ensemble auteurs de violences
quotidiennes
azzedine ça tombe bien vous allez
pouvoir répondre qu'est ce que vous êtes
maire le maire de tinqueux et voilà on
montrait du doigt en tout cas voilà ont
interpellé aujourd'hui par yvan à sur
mac
qu'est ce que vous répondez oui bonsoir
alors vont montrer du doigt je pense que
c'est un peu trop raccourci bon je peux
comprendre l'indignation de certains
policiers puisque au travers de
l'expression faite par le syndicat
alliance
de là à dire que le fait de marquer
violences policières aurait un message
qui incrimine un créneau horaire
l'ensemble de la police et l'ensemble
des policiers
je me vois je suis je m'inscris en
totalement faux par rapport à ça
monsieur as you may la question des
bonhommes policière n'a n'implique pas
forcément est directement le fait que
tous les policiers sont responsables
d'actes de violence y compris le nonce
policière c'est le cas de certains
policiers et je sais pour reconnaître
énormément et vous en connaissez
évidemment plus que moi que la grande
majorité des policiers faut très bien
leur travail
le faut avec j'irai avec sérieux avec
engagement que le service public
donc le fait d'évoquer la question du
racisme et des violences policières est
un terme qui est je ne suis pas je
dirais d'ailleurs ce sont des artistes
qui ont qui ont fait cette fresque donc
feu n'est pas moins qui a je ne suis pas
graffeurs à ma connaissance je suis lié
le maire
assez intelligent donc je vous remercie
de rappeler qu' il faut il faut faire
preuve d'intelligence donc je vous
rassure je suis quand même assez
intelligent donc l'expression des
graffeurs mettant en avant la question
du racisme et des violences policières
en aucun cas généralise et renvoie une
stigmatisation de l'ensemble des
policiers ça je pense qu'il faut être
très clair et d'ailleurs dans ce cas là
il faudrait à ce moment-là condamné et
il faudrait à ce moment-là vous indigner
monsieur assomma auprès du président de
la république auprès de votre ministre
de tutelle de l'intérieur et bien
d'autres personnes qui eux mêmes aussi
dans le vocabulaire employé le nombre le
nom de violences policières et je dirais
même plus le fait de parler de la
question de la violence policière et je
sais que au sein de la police vous êtes
nombreux et tant mieux et moi je salue
ce le travail qui est mené vous êtes
nombreux à travailler pour faire en
sorte que notre police républicaine et
quand vous je suis aussi très attaché
aux valeurs républicaines
soit une police je dirais qu'ils
respectent l'éthique qui respecte les
individus tout d'où qu'ils viennent et
je pense que là il ya un travail
important - je le dis je le dis encore
et je le fais dans mon quotidien avec
les policiers ici instinct ou de manière
générale avec les forces de l'ordre pour
que justement on donne un sens à
l'engagement qui est très important des
policiers un sens à l'engagement des
policiers avec la population donc voilà
je suis quand même assez surpris hier il
ya peut-être un contexte politique
national qui fait que les policiers sont
fortement remontés auprès du
gouvernement mais je voudrais pas que
justement cette fresque soit le prétexte
je dirais d'un différend tous les cas
d'un divorce qui existe entre entre
certains syndicats de la police
nationale et le gouvernement donc il
faudrait dans ce cas là
exigez d'effacer une bonne partie des
fresques que nous trouvons un peu
partout en france et parfois des
fresques avec des avec des injures
extrêmement grave que certainement vous
avez dû vous condamnez vous êtes
forcément indignés donc voilà je trouve
regrettable que cette polémique prennent
cette ampleur et c'est pour cette raison
quand j'ai su dès samedi que ce
rassemblement était prévu sur ça j'en ai
fait part au préfet je vous rappelle que
préfet n'étaient pas indignés il m'a
fait part du malaise que je peux que je
peux comprendre et d'ailleurs j'ai même
proposé de rencontrer de saintignon 15
avril le préfet monsieur taïbi et puis
on laissera aussi la parole thomas fait
pas évident à voir le préfet m'a fait
part je dirais de la colère et du
malaise au sein des policiers en voyant
cet amalgame fait entre racisme et
violences policières que cela jetait je
dirais du discrédit sur l'urgence des
policiers
totalement faux pas du tout pas du tout
et je pense même victime
on va laisser quand même répondre parce
que c'est un débat il veut y en a
sûrement qu'est ce que vous répondez
voilà à ces arguments
ce timing semble étonné par par cette
polémique par votre colère écoutez
d'abord ça me surprend pas monsieur
taïbi ils essayent de reporter cette
politique est sûre vers d'autres comme
il l'a dit et vers notre ministre vers
le gouvernement le gouvernement pardon
mais c'est pas ni le gouvernement ni
notre ministre qui a cautionné cette
cette fraise et surtout cette phrase
polémique comme on l'a rappelé aussi je
sais cette fresque elle a été fait sur
un mur qui appartient à la commune donc
a doublement la responsabilité du
premier du premier représentant de la
commune monsieur taïbi est engagé il
aurait dû je me répète mais il aurait dû
de lui même se douter que cette phrase à
l'aide polémique
un monsieur taïbi par la suite cessé
convenu d'un communiqué de presse dans
lequel aussi il rappelle qui sera là
derrière tous les gens qui sont victimes
d'injustice je vois pas le rapport avec
la fresque
ou alors il faut qu'on m'explique je
vais absolument pas parler moi
georges floyd et ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis ça nous concerne pas donc je
vous le rappelle le maire vous explique
vous vous mettez le doigt sur quelque
chose d'important ne suis qu'à ma part
ce serait prise et blanc explique or on
voit la fresque qui a été fait et qu'il
a inaugurées peut rappeler les gens
victimes d'injustices
je crois qu'il ya une affaire en cours
d'une enquête en cours pour l'instant
l'enquêté n'a pas déterminé qu'il y
avait une quelconque personne qui était
victime d'injustice monsieur taille les
jeux 2d j'allais venir parce que c'est
important ce point là ça veut dire que
vous vous validez la comparaison
voilà c'est une question entre joe fly
les fers de georges feydeau états unis
et la sphère adama traoré en france
puisque les deux noms sont associés sur
cette phase qui monsieur assurera la
rapée appartient à la commune les deux
les deux mots qui ont été cités dans
qu'adama traoré et georges floyd sont je
dirais la résultante d'une manière
générale des violences policières on
aurait pu enfin les artistes qui ont
fait cette fresque aurait pu
certainement imaginé de mettre plusieurs
visages
il est compliqué dans un dans un
périmètre comme celui ci de m une
quinzaine de visage mais on pourrait
parler aussi de d'autres faits de de
violences policières et je précise de
violences policières le qui sont je
dirais malheureusement parfois à
l'initiative de certains policiers et
pas de tous les policiers
je le précise et je ne cesse de le dire
à chaque fois parce que je sais que la
majorité des policiers font très bien
leur travail et parfois dans des
conditions difficiles moi j'suis le
premier d'ailleurs à me battre y compris
dans notre département comme la seine
saint denis je pense que monsieur me
faire rationnaires vous êtes bien
informé là dessus je me bats pour que
justement il est plus d'effectifs de
police dans nos villes y compris sur ce
temps quand on sait qu'on a un
commissariat qui est doté de moins de
policiers un tribunal qui est doté de
moins de 2 comment dire de deux joues de
juge ou de procureur donc voilà d'une
manière générale ce qu'il faut
clairement dire c'est que les violences
policières renvoie évidemment à beaucoup
d'affaires qui malheureusement à ce jour
n'ont pas été les filets vous allez me
dire c'est la justice de faire son
travail
bien sûr la justice fait son travail
mais en aucun cas elle jette je dirais
le propre auprès de toutes les policiers
mais
elle a aussi pour objectif comme
beaucoup de violence je suis désolé de
vous dire que les violences policières
font partie aussi des injustices qui
existent tout comme je m'intéresse à
réagir pardonnez moi ce que je voudrais
vous faire réagir sans cette petite
phrase prononcée par la porte parole du
gouvernement si bethesda qui était
invitée d'une émission politique
notamment sur l'interpellation un récent
d'une infirmière qui jetaient des
projectiles sur les crs voici ce qu'elle
a répondu je ne saurais pas expliquer à
mes enfants s'il est normal ou pas de
jeter des pierres sur les forces de
l'ordre
c'était court ils vont as you may que
vous inspire cette phrase de la porte
parole du gouvernement à écouter je
crois que ça dépasse l'entendement je me
permets de rappeler à la porte parole du
gouvernement que jeter des projectiles
sur les policiers
c'est un délit est par définition c'est
interdit et que je crois qu'il ya aucun
policier qui a un problème pour
l'expliquer à ses enfants
voilà ça fait ça ça se démontre
simplement un amateurisme de la porte
parole qui ne connaît pas le sujet je
voudrais revenir quand même sur ce que
monsieur le maire de saint a dit je
trouve ça grave je trouve ça garde ce
qui vient de dire notamment que le dit
que radio m a aidée par traoré a été
victime de violences policières
je me permets d'émettre des réserves et
lui rappeler qu'il ya une enquête en
cours il ya une instruction qui en cours
et on se voit bien le garder de faire ce
genre de raisonnement et de faire ce
genre de raccourcis mais je pense que
les avocats qui sont chargés de défendre
les gendarmes seront apprécié la faim et
la réponse justement une enquête est en
cours
votre réponse oui une enquête est en
cours mais parmi les éléments de
l'enquète beaucoup d'éléments montrent
qu il qu'il y a eu un très grave
problème lors de l'interpellation de
monsieur adama traoré
donc je pense que personne ne peut le
nier évidemment l'argument c'est à dire
mais son enquête
je dirai ce s'organiser ça fait déjà
calmes depuis quelques années mais vous
savez l'indignation aussi monsieur à
somain il faut comprendre aussi
l'indignation des familles
qui attendent des réponses claires et
parfois pendant de très nombreuses
années je pense en particulier un ami
njiang qui a été acquis est mort il ya
pratiquement 11 ans comprenait aussi
l'indignation c'est même plus de la
colère pour ces familles c'est les
familles qui sont totalement je dirais
totalement déçu et est totalement
abasourdi au fait qu'il n'y a pas de
réponse de la justice
l'indignation elle existe aussi au côté
des familles et je pense qu'il est
important à la fois l'institution
policière mais aussi les familles de
trouver et je le dis à chaque fois et
c'est pour ça que j'ai j'ai invité le
syndicat à me rencontrer et à échanger
certainement qu'il y aura des points de
désaccord et c'est bien normal ça fait
partie aussi les sensibilités que nous
pouvons avoir
mais je suis certain qu'on pourra
trouver des points d'accord pour
démontrer que souvent et c'est le cas en
seine saint denis je le redis parce que
pour moi c'est lié le fait que des
policiers travaillent très souvent dans
des conditions extrêmement difficiles
et puis vous savez les injustices je les
condamne aussi quand elles sont aussi
dirigés vers des policiers et je le fais
à chaque fois je pense que vous êtes
bien informé si vous regardez un petit
peu dans les réseaux sociaux à chaque
fois j'exprime très clairement et dans
des communiqués de presse wal
indignation quand les policiers sont
tués quand des policiers était plein
temps et ça pour moi c'est important
donc pour moi il ya je n'ai pas une
position à géométrie variable je combats
toutes les formes d'injustice
non merci à ces détails mais pardonnez
moi je vous coupe parce que vous vous
coupez pas vous même
merci également ils vont à soma a versé
à tous les deux d'avoir été avec moi